in this video we'll be talking about a
quick concept about bilaminar embryonic
dis this is a terminology used in
embryology so we are looking at second
week of embryonic development and at
this point of time at around day seven
the embryo is known as the blastocyst
blastocyst would eventually be embedded
into the endometrium so let's look at
the layers of the blastocyst the outer
layer in this beige color is known as
trophoblast the red layer is the Inner
Cell Mass let me clarify the Inner Cell
mass is the future embryo the
trophoblast would provide supportive
structures in a moment it would be clear
but the inner me Inner Cell mass is the
future
embryo bilaminar embrionic dis is a two
layered structure which has first the
hypoblast and the ablast layer here you
can see the blue layer is the hypoblast
and the red layer is AP blast and the
cavity between them is the amniotic
cavity now the hypoblast consists of
cuboidal cell whereas the AP Blast has
columnar cells so obviously these two
layers are distinct and this structure
is known as the bilaminar embryonic disk
we would eventually understand what is
the fate of this bilaminar embryonic dis
but before that let me clarify that
trophoblast is the outer layer which
further divides into
cytotrophoblast and the cotrol blast
cytotrophoblast help the blast is to get
embedded into the endometrium and the
cot trophoblast plays an important role
in fetal and maternal exchange so this
is basically the future
placenta now hypoblast the layer from
the bilaminar embryonic dis eventually
give rise to the Primitive yok Sac it's
important to note that before the
placenta is formed and the Maternal
Fetal blood connection is established
yac is the key entity which give
nutrition and help in gas exchange for
the embryo now the other component of
the bilaminar embryonic disc is the AP
blast now here the AP blast is again in
the red and hypoblast is in the green
remember AP blast is actually the future
embryos all the layers of the embryo
would be formed from the epiblast by the
process of gastrulation three distinct
germ layers namely ectoderm mesoderm and
endoderm would be formed eventually in
the the third week of the human
embryonic development and this is
happening at around day 16 or day
15 we have a detailed video about each
of these week of the development all the
links are provided in the ey button you
can also look at the process of gulation
is in much more details all the links
would be found in ion